بعد شاراريا يجتمع الجميع
معًا لتناول يخنة بيريا خاليسكو الشهيرة
هولا إنريكي
[موسيقى] كانت
عائلة إنريكي تطبخ هذه
الوصفة لأربعة أجيال وهو الآن
رئيس الطهاة في نادي لينزو
[موسيقى]
أحضر الإسبان الماعز من الحليب
لكن الماعز تولت المهمة  وأكلوا جميع
محاصيل السكان الأصليين، لذلك على الرغم من أن
أكل الماعز بدأ
للسيطرة على الأضرار، إلا أن النتيجة النهائية كانت
انتصارًا في الطهي، فقد جلبوا كل شيء ولكنك
جعلت الأمر أفضل،
هناك عنصران بالضبط لوسائط اللحم
والصلصة،
يطحن إنريكي خليج الثوم  الأوراق والقرنفل
مع الخل الروائح السحرية
التي تعطي الوسائط مذاقها الفريد وهذا
فقط طماطم حسنًا،
يتم دمج الطماطم والبهارات المطحونة
مع عصائر اللحم
أوه واو مثل ما يجعلها مميزة
الشخص الذي يصنعها واو
[موسيقى]
نعم حياة  جيد مع وسائل الإعلام،
انظر إلى ذلك،
أوه، يمكنك شم رائحة القرنفل باللغة
الإسبانية، وهي وسيلة قليلة القيمة
لطعام رجل فقير
[موسيقى]
ولكن من المفارقات اليوم أنه طعام مناسب لمأدبة
البطل،
لدي الكثير من الذكريات،
واو، هذه الرائحة جيدة جدًا، كما تعلم
[موسيقى]
هممم
واو
واو،
إنه ناعم جدًا،
يا إلهي، هذا المرق مذهل
أستطيع أن أرى لماذا أصبح يخنة الجاليسكون
أسطورية مثل تشارلز الذي
أكله، لقد حولوا
لحم الماعز بمهارة إلى أحد أعمدة
فن الطهي المكسيكي، هذا هو  من المدهش حقًا أن
هؤلاء تشارلز الماكر لديهم خدعة أخرى
في جعبتهم
مثل هذه يا
إلهي، إنها محاولة كبيرة جدًا
لقتلي، إنه أول يوم لي وهم يحاولون
قتلي
[ضحك]
[تصفيق]